if you know one thing about me it's that
i follow the science wherever the
science goes i'm there if it heads to
the bar
i'll follow it and buy it a shot if it
says room 110 and bring the whip
i'll be there in a mask but if you
follow the science and think it's always
dr fauci
you'll be chasing your tail like a
beagle with ocd
the man changes his story more often
than a suspect on columbo
right now at this moment there is no
need to change
anything that you're doing on a
day-by-day basis but as soon as it
became clear
that there was community spread then it
became clear that we were in real
trouble when we were around when was
that well that was probably towards the
middle to end of january
right now in the united states people
should not be walking around
with masks putting a mask on yourself
is more to prevent you
from infecting someone else and if
everybody does that
we're each protecting each other if one
mask is good
two masks are better maybe three
you could wear fouchy on the beach he's
such a flip-flop but it's not his fault
science changes and as we learn more we
don't ignore new
facts that would be stupid unless you
still think the earth is flat
the dumbest lie ever made was the
science is settled
and fauchy's right to say what he thinks
is right for that moment he's not
blinded by science
just spotlights it's when he looks
backward
and opinions replace prescriptions just
to tickle the media
reuters claimed fauci said the pandemic
arrived in the u.s as the country was
riven by political divisions
in which wearing a mass became a
political statement
says who and maybe that could have
killed more people
but that's an opinion and it's an odd
one for a doctor who made equivocation
over masks in art form you could say
wear a mask all the time or take it off
outdoors you could say no to clothing
closing schools then yes you could say
it's safe to travel then it's not
you could say vaccines will return us to
normalcy
except without the normalcy you could
say all this because i think he kind of
did
but this was a novel virus so it's all
novel to him and to us
but assigning a death count to an
opinion is a bit much especially when
expert opinions change so much the thing
about covid
it killed a lot of our loved ones but
not our memories
of them or of the advice we heard right
and wrongly
dana are judging by the uh impersonation
i'm doing i'm going to throw
to uh some sound on tape by fox news uh
uh
contributor do you know who that is
right here yes
we're going to throw to brittany scott
brittahoon has a theory on
uh fouchy uh let's go to that
the problem i think with dr fauci is not
so much with him
him as it is with our failure as a
society
to recognize that he is a an expert
in a narrow field he's an epidemiologist
his job is to fight this disease he's
not
a an expert in child psychology or
children's education he's not an
authority on the u.s
economy and the damage that may be done
to it he's just not
it's an interesting point he's like he's
got one lane
the problem is is when he has to comment
outside that lane
well and i think there's a law of
diminishing returns
um that is a scientific fact uh law of
diminishing returns
um for his media appearances he is
very generous with his time and media
love to have him he's great for ratings
people love to watch
but now he's even taken incoming from
the media that has loved him
because they're like well wait because
it was but the schools were open but
they're not open but now you have to get
the stimulus money
for the schools in order for them to
open and it does get you into a
situation where you sound
inconsistent uh and sometimes
disingenuous and so
if i were there if i could give a little
advice to those folks there
i he i i don't think he needs to say yes
to every single interview
yeah um he could do you know even if
they just did one briefing a day i think
that would be fine
i think it was good early on remember he
was willing to go on some of those
uh podcasts and different things that he
hadn't seen that dr
fauci do before and that was i think
helpful at the beginning but
right now it's just way too much media
he's watered down the message he's
confused the message
and i think that even he would probably
agree with that that
stepping back from all of these media
appearances would help all of us
juan uh should fauci be impeached
uh no you know i gotta tell you i think
actually
uh you know and just in response to dana
i think
having fatchi out there i think the
audience is still there and i think the
message is so important in terms of
people getting vaccinations giving
people you don't think he's been
you don't think he's in a situation now
where he to greg's point he showed it i
mean there are inconsistencies
no i think i don't see the i think greg
made a good point but it's not that
their inconsistencies it's that as greg
said the science evolved so if fauchi is
saying
back in march and april hey listen
you don't need to wear a mask and it
turns out he was concerned about the
stockpile of mass for people who were in
hospitals and the like
okay but then he was saying wear a mask
by april and may and june and you know
it was president trump who was saying
he's not going to wear a mask it was
president trump who was
mocking joe biden i've never seen a man
so big making fun of reporters wearing
masks
and he certainly knew by then what was
going on and what struck me today was
that it's not just
dr fauci it's francis collins the
director
of the national uh institute who said
you know trump politicized mass he made
it a statement of your political
affiliation a statement or a declaration
about you
you know personal freedom what about you
what about the opening of school
health yeah well he's not saying i think
it's been very
it's been very clear that you you know
we have to open schools but
you have to do it safely no but they
said schools could be open
the cdc director said the schools could
be open then they said she was speaking
in her personal capacity and they wanted
that's x amount money more for the
stimulus bill
and that's what ended up happening and
then they said oh we actually need to
get the schools open you have to have
the stimulus bill sorry i've
spoken way more than i usually do you
were smoking what dana
yes hey um jesse i there's a there's a
neat little trick and and
you saw it there with juan it's uh when
somebody states an opinion
that they don't like it's a political oh
they're making the the masks political
and when trump banned travel oh that was
political until the experts said yeah
that was a good move
so it's like as long anything that you
do you politicize the topic
but they don't or if they flip-flop
they're not flip-flopping they're
evolving because the science has evolved
so mass shaming which fauci is involved
in is just so democrats can blame trump
supporters
for the pandemic instead of china
fauci's doing it to shift blame because
we saw half a million people die during
a pandemic in which
he was the country's top infectious
disease doctor
and trump followed almost everything he
recommended right so a little bit of
this
is on blame shifting i went back and
looked at the polls
in october before the second wave on
mask wearing
90 percent of the country puts a mask
on before they leave the house 89 of
conservatives
put a mask on before they leave the
house so if
90 of the country's wearing a mask then
why do we have a second wave
and why did cases and deaths in
california explode
when all the liberals slapped on masks
it's because mass are not a silver
bullet so stop trying to blame
well the the nine percent of loud
anti-massacres out there
that didn't cause the pandemic good
point and dagon
if we want to talk about
politicalization of a topic
probably the most repulsive political
act was pelosi withholding aid
to americans in order to beat trump i
mean
that's pretty harsh yeah standing atop
the suffering because she thinks it
makes her look
taller because it makes the suffering of
americans because it makes her
more powerful it's disgusting uh i want
to pick up on dana's point really
quickly
fauci did say that we need to pass the
stimulus to open schools
without mentioning that 90 or more
of the 68 billion allocated last year
for k through 12 of schools hadn't even
been spent
he didn't even mention that so clearly
he is carrying water for the biden
administration from the outside looking
in it looks like
somebody in the administration said uh
hey tony
he's up on the good news until we pass
this
uh port-tastic stimulus bill you know
go out there and scare the doobies off
of people
i just want to raise this is somebody
born
a craven partisan hack or do you
become one you know being around all of
these insufferable sycophants down in
washington
is this something you can catch maybe
tony
you could get yeah maybe tony about
fauci could get on that and
and fill us in heck he would tell you to
wear a mask and then not to wear a mask
and then to wear a mask and then not to
wear a mask
and then he would grin and go like this
he's a good man just do less media
there you go that's true for everybody
dress exactly